you know  [Music]  one of these villages like us traveling  forward through time the other one's  going backwards  can you tell which is which  how about now  [Music]  why does it feel so strange you're not  shooting the bullet  you're catching it whoa i didn't win  back in my cell  felt like hell worse  [Applause]  by the way  for a diplomat  there are people in the future who need  us  [Music]  you get something you're not gonna like  time isn't the problem getting out alive  that's a problem  [Music]  when i dance  well i'm going so any tips will be  welcome ain't no time i'm facing scams  do you think we're saying  the detritus of a coming war  [Music]  you want to crash a plane well how big a  plane  that part is a little dramatic  last time it was no tennis ready pg-13